[Music]
well donald trump isn't the president
anymore
and that means you haven't heard a lot
about russia recently that
is until yesterday when joe biden gave
an interview designed to remind us he's
a very tough man
so you know vladimir putin you think
he's a killer
i do so what price must he pay the price
he's going to pay well you'll see
shortly
putin's going to pay because he's a
killer says the guy who just sent
missiles into syria for no obvious
reason
putin responded by challenging biden to
a debate which honestly would be worth
watching
we want to hear biden out though so
let's take a close look at russia's
record
very upset about russia what have they
done we've committed genocide
they've bought up the entire third world
in africa and latin america they're
literally building all the
infrastructure in the bahamas
in our hemisphere they're stealing our
jobs our intellectual property they're
dumping tons of fentanyl into this
country which has killed more than a
hundred thousand people
they filled our universities with spies
they're trying to dominate the world
oh but wait that's not russia russia
didn't unleash a virus that destroyed
our economy
and left millions unemployed china did
that china
and the dictator who runs it xi jinping
joe biden knows this
he knows russia isn't an existential
threat to the united states but he keeps
talking about it
because he doesn't want to talk about
china his family has made
millions apparently from china countless
others in the corporate and ruling elite
have too
but it's putin who's going to pay and
not just putin you're also going to pay
you you're about to pay a lot more on
taxes biden told us that as well
yes anybody making more than four
hundred thousand dollars
will see a small to a significant tax
increase if you make less than four
hundred thousand dollars you won't see
one single penny in additional federal
tax
so what biden didn't explain is why he
wants to raise taxes and by the way
we're not going to give you the
conventional conservative take on taxes
the grover norquist take which is
you know you could never raise them
that's not the point at all the point is
much bigger than that the point is why
do we have taxes
in the first place at this point we
don't fund the government with tax
revenue
we fund it with money that the federal
reserve creates how do we just pay for a
two trillion dollar
relief bill it wasn't tax money that did
that we just printed the money
so actually taxes are kind of beside the
point at this stage
democrats could tax all the income in
the united states and they still
wouldn't balance the budget or pay off
the debt in fact they'd be about 10
trillion
dollars short of paying off the debt
they could go after your assets like
your home and your savings and
retirement accounts maybe they'll try
that
elizabeth warren has been trying that
for a long time but the question is
since we're not funding the government
with tax revenue we've decided that
modern monetary theory is real like we
could just print money because we're the
reserve currency
why would you even consider raising
taxes on families making 400 grand
why do that at this point you don't need
to
to punish you obviously individual
americans
making paying taxes make up the largest
part of u.s tax revenue they account for
about 42 percent of all the taxes the
government takes in
what's the smallest source of tax
revenue oh
the donors corporate taxes those account
for about 3.9 percent of all taxes
joe biden knows that tax increases
aren't going to hurt corporations or
private equity firms they won't touch
ivy league endowments they'll leave the
bill and melinda gates foundation
completely alone no billionaire is going
to suffer
you're going to suffer and for no good
reason because to restate one more time
we don't fund the government with tax
revenue we fund the government with
money the federal reserve makes up out
of nothing
that's true and no one says it
so coming on tonight to make some sense
of this biden interview in order russia
in texas
is victor davis hanson about the wisest
person we know he joins us now professor
thanks so much for coming on so first
to russia this obsession this is not a
defense of putin's regime or of russia
or anything like that but why
the focus the relentless focus on russia
yeah i don't know it's always a bad idea
tucker to
gratuitously call a killer the head of
state with 7 000
deliverable nuclear weapons and
there's no standard i don't know whether
uh
putin has not killed 20 million people
like his communist
predecessors he is not uh the communist
party in china that has the blood of 70
million
people on their hand and a million
people in camps we could go on and on
with north koreans
the castroid regime in cuba so there's
no standard by which you
single out somebody and not the other it
reminds me though
we're missing what henry kissinger told
us 40 years ago and he was real politic
he said
we don't want china to be a better
friend to russia than they are
to each of each one to us because we
actually do have some common interests
with putin
we are both wary of islamic terrorism
and we both
don't want china to run the world and we
along
with the russians in india can check
china if we don't throw away that card
so
this anger comes out of the russian
collusion hoax but even earlier
they came into power biden and obama and
they said bush was too hard on china
we're going to reset and putin as the
auto crowd he is
he interpreted that magnum entity as
weakness to be exploited and finally we
got to the
surreal situation where obama was
trading necessary missile defense
so that biden would behave during his
reelection which he didn't even do
although he gave up missile defense so i
think they're
a little bit humiliated especially after
22 months and
40 million dollars didn't find any
russian collusion that was a hoax
and so yeah it's just an obsession now
it's a religion
yeah and russia is also the only big
country in the world that doesn't buy
our woke program and i think that drives
them
they won't take the pronouns drives them
so i have to ask you about taxes
so we've decided that we can fund a two
trillion dollar relief bill just by
printing the money
so clearly taxes are sort of irrelevant
to run the government now
why are they so eager to tax us
well i think it's to punish people and
tell their base that we're going to
redistribute
income but the fact is we're running a
2.3 trillion dollar
annual budget deficit we're getting up
to 29 trillion
in aggregate debt national debt and the
only way to get out of that is either to
do what trump tried to do
although he didn't he didn't address the
spending and that is deregulate
and have tax incentives and have full
employment but
when you mention as biden and his
associates are that they're going to
raise taxes on
the productive classes they're going to
have more regulations
they're going to stifle energy
production and yet they're going to
borrow more money than the only way out
is
zero interest rates and either inflation
or stagflation or recession are all and
combined in the way that we saw
in the 1970s that got ronald reagan
elected
and that's where we're headed we have no
margin of error now we can't borrow
money
to get out of a recession because we're
in debt to an extending of
a degree we can't uh you know lower
interest rates because they don't really
exist
we're already there so i don't know what
stimuli we have when we hit the
recession it's all been used up i've
noticed
why is anyone paying any taxes since
they're just printing the money and
burdening our kids with it
vic james hanson i appreciate your
insights thank you
thank you thank you